Adam chapters interview with Greg hardy
airs on NFL live today that's a two
thirty eastern on espn2 and adam kind
enough to join us on short notice how
did the interview come about Adam well
daddy was a situation where I station we
talked about it and brought up the idea
to him and he said yeah I'll keep it in
mind he was staged to Gary be interested
in doing it so I flew into Memphis
yesterday drew over an Oxford
Mississippi where Greg's three credits
shy of finishing the degree at all this
we spent about an hour and a half
together we spoke over the phone over
the weekend a handful time teen I and
basically the injuries running touché
afternoon on Anton ciders NFL live and
they're gonna play and you'll know you
appreciate this that about 15 minutes
worth which in TV and ESPN is a long
time yeah yeah and he was very expensive
on a lot of topics in very interesting a
lot of topics and uh I'd never really
sat down and explained his side in his
version of events surrounding that
particular case and does it stem from
him not having work I think that's a
fair assumption but obviously the median
jury went far beyond that because he's
never had to answer any questions about
that particular situation and he finally
did do that any parameters 0 it asks
whatever I wanted and uh we were going
in that I can ask whatever I wanted so
no there was nothing like that at all of
course did you ask him why this girl his
ex-girlfriend did not testify the second
time room yeah I did ask him that and um
I have to go look at the transcript
exactly but I asked her what happened
why she didn't show up and I don't think
he had a specific explanation i know
people suspicions are up i think he went
through the incident then and he spelled
out his mom
you heard the fact that he felt like he
swore and was adamant and insistent that
he never once placed a hand on this
woman and after why howdy how does she
come up with some of the bruises and
everything that she did in the pictures
and um I'll just say this that he you
know afternoon two years old were
talking more and he's like look let me
place them right now I would I would
swear on the life of my parents and my
newborn son but I never touched this one
and he was with a friend that night who
apparently was uh um restraining this
woman from attacking him that now again
I'm this is his version you people could
believe what they want he's never talked
about it before I asked him why that was
like why did you wait till now gray and
his contention was that he was always
getting different opinions from
different people his lawyers would say
don't talk is agent perte du talk is he
would say don't talk and so there are a
lot of voices and he didn't know how to
handle it and he literally do not handle
it the right way and when he says I
haven't done everything right when I
asked him specifically about that
incident with this woman at that
particular time of what do you need him
to all right right what does that mean
and what he meant by that was he feels
like he should not have put himself in
that situation around that woman at that
time a night around alcohol and now is
his mistake he should never have done
that but in his mind he swears he never
put a finger on this woman and people
could believe what they want do you
believe it doesn't matter what I
believed in right well does having a
conversation with you after the fact if
I I mean you're you're still objective
with this I'll say this I'll say this to
you I went in there with the idea that
everybody had that this guy's a monster
okay I went in there thinking this is
one of scariest people the NFL and I
came out of there with a very different
feeling
about him I came out of there with a
feeling that this is a guy who has
managed to say the wrong things at the
wrong times has not always made the
right decisions but I I thought him to
be uh a change kind of guy I got that um
I think realized he did make some
mistakes um could have handled things
differently in regards to that incident
it's such a tough thing I'd like to talk
to more people before I made a judgment
all I can go by the word he said I'll
finish he was he wasn't wavering he was
adamant I never touched this woman but
he also dimensions look he mentions the
Bible but then you know the truth will
set you free so if you really believe
you're innocent you should have taken
this long it feels like it's a desperate
move to have somebody bring him in and
hire him it look I get it this what
agents do they polish it up and put him
put him in front of a camera but look
you did your job that did did was there
a bed of guns there that does he have a
bed of guns that night but uh well I a
surviving a specific at abetik I didn't
ask that question then come and maybe I
should have yeah I didn't have that
question but what I asked her about guns
like how do you how do you make the
comic decision uncle about guns blazing
before your first game when you're
accused of throwing this woman onto a
bed of guns like how do you say that and
you know he he admits that he said the
wrong things little time where that's
coming from his agent or him I don't
know okay but um I think you know
they're clearly seems to be good enough
farmers that night on the basis of what
transpired in the court testimony and
then those records yeah before I let you
go a week from now Colin Kaepernick will
be where you know I know people saying
the deals that I just think
everybody posturing right now and and
and I I think that we have to see how
this plays out all the way after the
dress because I think Denver could
decide to give him someone money maybe
colin kaepernick surrenders one money
maybe shampoo kicked him right now every
side each side is entrenched in its
dance I'm not budging mystic and maybe
that'll be the case for three weeks
maybe but maybe not yeah I think he
still ends up there Adam got great job
thank you Joe what thank you buddy
that's Adam Schefter ESPN NFL insider
the Greg hardy interview airs on NFL
live today at two thirty eastern on
espn2 the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience